figaro live bonjour on en dirait que ce
matin pour suivre la situation en
ukraine
je suis avec alexis faire chaque du
service actu du figaro adjoint au pôle
actu du figaro bonjour on
va décrypter la situation grâce aux
cartes le nombreuses cartes fait grâce
au service infographie du figaro je vais
vous montrer ça tout de suite voilà
c'est la première carte que voulez vous
montrer alexis la première question que
j'avais pour vous c'est on voit sur
cette carte qu'il s'agit d'une attaque
coordonnée mais il s'attaque il s'agit
d'une attaque coordonnée et puis surtout
on voit bien là sur la sur la carte elle
ya plusieurs fronts et notamment dans
2014 y avait eu une
première invasion russe mais qui étaient
dans le donbass avec les séparatistes
pro-russes le dombass est vraiment
laisse de l'ukraine on voit les deux
oblast donc province de lougansk est
donné sur la sur la carte et l'envoi il
s'agit pas du tout la même chose s'ils
n'attaquent et au nord et à l'est et au
sud donc c'est extrêmement différents en
fait ça a commencé c'est un peu comme
une guerre comme la guerre d'irak on est
dans en 2003 par les états unis sien des
frappes ciblées
extrêmement puissante conques ont eu
lieu entre dans la nuit de mercredi à
jeudi
pour cibler notamment les défenses
aériennes et les radars les centres de
commandement externe en a eu dans tout
le pays on voit même que l'île des
frappes ce cas le vif en le vif c'est
vraiment l'extrême ouest du pays à la
frontière polonaise donc on voit que
c'était des frappes globale et ça
c'était à l'eau mais ensuite il ya eu
l'offensive terrestre a commencé
et en ce qui est peut-être un premier
bilan mais ce qui est très intéressant
c'est qu'il n'y a pas eu d'effondrement
des forces armées ukrainiennes
c'était évidemment une crainte à kiev or
là on voit que sur les trois fronts au
nord à l'est et au sud il n'y a pas eu
d'effondrement même si évidemment le
rapport de force
militaire est très clairement en
défaveur de la réussissait à la fois sur
le plan quantitatif
les le format russe aujourd'hui les il
se constitue autour de son appel les
groupements tactiques
c'est en fait d
c'est à peu près 1000 hommes mais avec
des moyens la fois blindés des moyens
d'artillerie
et dont il y en a 120 qui étaient massés
depuis un mois autour de la autour des
frontières du lks rennes donc c'est 100
120 mille hommes et la lance sources
américaines disent qu'il y aurait déjà
60 de ces groupes tactiques qui sont
engagés voilà donc c'est absolument
énorme environ 60000 l'homme a priori et
donc à des enfants qui sont toujours
possibles donc le rapport de force il
est en faveur des russes s'est néanmoins
à ce jour il n'y a pas eu d'effondrement
complet du fonds néanmoins on est au
moins on va voir les forces armées
russes sont quand même aux portes de
kiev progresse bien effectivement et un
jugement vous le disiez le ccc attaque
on s'attendait peut-être que vanille
repli ne s'attendait à une attaque un
peu est clair qu'ils arriveraient à
récupérer a très rapidement le pays
finalement ça n'est pas vraiment le cas
alors déjà il faut me dirai qu'une chose
l'ukraine ces cinq cent mille six cent
mille kilomètres carrés
c'est légèrement plus lent que la france
c'est le plus grand pays d'europe alors
évidemment comme ça côté la russie on se
rend un peu moins content mais en face
c'est quand même gigantesque et il faut
aussi mesurer que pour la russie une
invasion
peut-être pas totale du pays mais met
enfin en tout cas massive de l'ukraine
c'est une opération de très grande
envergure et
et donc là encore
il n'ya pas de blitzkrieg il ya pas de
guerre éclaire enfin néanmoins les les
rues seront fortement avancé à kiev mais
aussi on le verra dans le sud à partir
de la crimée
est aussi un peu leste oui bien sûr on
va parler de ces différents fronts le
premier front on peut en parler c'est le
front du nord via la biélorussie et
surtout très proche de kiev au final
voilà c'est ça qui est très intéressant
en fait il ya un repère géographique en
ukraine qui est très important à
conserver l'esprit c'est le sien fleuve
sai l'uniap qui dont je caricature un
peu mais il traverse l'ukraine du nord
au sud et en fait si vous allez au nord
de l'ukraine à la frontière avec la
biélorussie vous descendez le nième 250
km à peu près et vous tomber sur la
capitale kiev alors aujourd'hui les
dernières informations qu'on a c'est que
il ya des combats
on va pas dire dans kiev n'a pas encore
la certitude en tout cas aux pentes de
kiev ou
avec l'armée russe donc là ça donne peut
être une idée des objectifs de vladimir
poutine des objectifs stratégiques
parce que s'ils prennent kiev donc c'est
la capitale est ce qu'il peut faire
tomber le gouvernement le régime et ont
entraîné une démoralisation complète des
troupes donc là en tout cas ils sont que
la grande offensive
elle sonne ll son honneur alors c'était
assez intéressant parce que hier il ya
eu une opération qui était visiblement
assez osée par les troupes aéroportées
russes elle est l'élève et dv qui sont
assez mythique en aussi la seconde
guerre mondiale en fait ils ont envoyé
un assaut d'hélicoptères
entre 20 et 30 hélico et qui se sont
posés dans un aéroport au nord-ouest de
kiev est halal alors même que les
troubles ce n'était pas du tout afin
qu'il m'aide autre gaffe ils sont posés
ils ont pris le
l'aéroport et en l'idée c'était de créer
une probablement une tête de pont aérien
pour ensuite pouvoir attaquer
directement la capitale
visiblement il ya une contre attaque
ukrainienne
hier en tout cas n'est pas de renfort
russes n'ont pu se poser sur l'aéroport
et là franchement la situation est très
très incertaine les ukrainiennes hier
soir tard ont dit qu'ils allaient repris
l'aéroport bref c'est compliqué en tout
cas ce qui est sûr c'est que les forces
armées russes sont aux pans de kef c'est
effectivement très confus on le sait en
temps de guerre comme ça il ya une
guerre de la communication et qui se
joue je veux saluer dans le tchat il y à
arcalis major et manga qui viennent de
nous rejoindre n'hésitez pas à du coup à
nous poser vos questions sur ses cartes
on a parlé du front du nord on peut être
parler du front de l'est puisque c'est
ces régions qui étaient des arbres qui
étaient concernés principalement
absolument alors déjà on voit que c'est
un front assez très étendue ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose qu'il faut
répéter mais le front là dans son
ensemble c'est vraiment plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres donc c'est assez
énorme on va partir du plus simple c'est
à dire du dombass
c'est là c'est de là que tout est parti
en 2014 j'ai très peu rappeler où elle
tomba sur la carte alors le dombass vous
voyez louanges donesk c'est les deux
régions les plus à l'est de l'ukraine
c'est des régions qui sont
traditionnellement très russophone alors
attention c'est pas parce qu'on est
russophone
qu'on est forcément pro russe au sens où
l'on doit être rattaché à la russie mais
en tout cas on en parlera peut-être tout
à l'heure pour des raisons historiques
il ya il ya une proximité culturelle et
linguistique avec les russes et donc en
2014 quand il ya eu la révolution du
maiden qui était pro européenne et bien
eu il ya eu des révoltes dans l'est de
l'ukraine notamment dans le bon basse
évidemment qu'on était encouragé par le
kremlin et
il ya eu des forces séparatistes qui ont
émergé clairement aidé par l'armée russe
et en 2014 une vraie guerre faut le
rappeler mais qui était une guerre
limitée au donbass qui a fait dix mille
morts à peu près en huit ans sauf que la
plupart des combats ont eu lieu en 2014
il ya eu les accords de paix en 2015 qui
ont délimité en tout cas fixé une ligne
de front
convoi civil et en fait les séparatistes
n'ont pas pris tout le dombass
l'ensemble du nom basse
c'est les zones orange lancé s'arrête là
mais c'est aussi les zones rayé ça c'est
les deux oblath les deux provinces de
données élégance et la zone de front à
ses limites entre les deux
mais on rappelle aussi que les flèches
qu'on a qu'on a matérialisé sur la carte
c'est les offensives russe voilà et
c'est ça et donc du coup
hier de façon assez logique il ya aussi
des offensives qui ont été menées depuis
le donbass séparatiste
sachant que l'étonnement commeinhes
c'est pas la principale
l'abonnement ou pas d'ailleurs la
principale offensive ne vient pas du nom
basse
voilà il ya eu d'autres choix
stratégiques et tactiques on compte
qu'on était prêts ont néanmoins si on
peut
zoomer encore un peu plus ses passions
pour asus de n'ont alors pas augmenter
le sud en tout cas voilà le sud de
donetsk
ya un port qui pèle marine pool qui dort
qui donne sur la mer d'azov la mer
d'azov on le voit très bien c'est une
mer fermée qu'un accès qui est fermé par
la crimée et on peut avoir accès à la
mer noire juste par le détroit de kertch
donc c'est une zone également importante
très tactique de portneuf tactique on se
rappelle qu'en 2014 d'ailleurs la crimée
c'est énorme je parle de l'écrit mais
mais en tout cas là dans le combat ce
port de mariupol les rebelles en 2014
s'était arrêtée vraiment l entrée de la
ville hélas il y a
des combats qui sont en cours à mon avis
je dernières informations la ville les
pas prise mais en tout cas c'est un
endroit très important si maintenant
toujours sur le front de l'est on
remonte au nord le le front de l'ess ne
vient pas seulement des territoires
séparatistes il vient aussi des
territoires de la russie proprement dit
et notamment depuis des semaines depuis
toutes les troupes bruce s'annonce la
frontière ukrainienne y avait une ville
qu'on regarde énormément qui s'appelle
belgorod alors mme hedegaard s'est pas
sur la carte mais en fait c'est juste en
face de la très grande ville de kharkiv
qu'on voit à peu près là au milieu
est et kharkiv est vraiment à la
frontière ukrainienne c'est à 20 30 km
de la frontière et c'est pas du tout
anodin c'est la deuxième ville du pays
par sa population ce à peu près un
million et demi d'habitants et donc
c'est un objectif également très
important pour les russes qu'ont pour le
coup fait une avancée très massive vers
kharkiv alors pareil ils sont dans les
formes au faubourg de kharkiv à ce jour
ils n'ont pas de prix
kharkiv
voilà est-ce que ça changera dans la
journée ça on le verra izneo aussi un
peu avancé au nord on va pas rentrer
dans les détails mais voilà ça c'est
pour le front de l'est effectivement et
on vous rappelle qu effectivement les
informations qu'on vous donne maintenant
société de changer à tout moment sous le
nom se base sur les informations qu'on a
nous via la fp aussi via nos reporters
qui sont sur place on rappelle qu on a
du monde sur place nos reporters qui
nous donnent des informations et en
temps réel je précise juste un point
c'est que sur les réseaux sociaux il ya
plein de vidéos qui sont très
intéressante en soi mais il ya avant la
formation et la traiter et donc parfois
on a un temps de latence par rapport à
ce qu'on peut voir sur twitter ou mais
c'est important de rester prudent je
prends un exemple hier soir il y avait
la ville de soumis on avait annoncé
qu'elle avait été reprise
fait qu'elle a été prise par les russes
ce matin il y avait des vidéos qui sont
gérés qui a été reprise par les
ukrainiens franchement j'en sais rien ne
vaut mieux être prudent ces services il
faut rappeler que c'est une vraie guerre
de l'information qui se joue depuis
guéri dans la formation avec c'est pas
juste une guerre de communiqués on le
voit c'est avant tout bien qu'ils
trouvent sur les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui et notamment avec des vidéos
qui sont pris par l'agressivité
oui voilà une vidéo qui qui émergent
partout donc soyez prudent avec ce que
vous regardez à former avec des sources
sûres comme on aime vous le rappeler
depuis hier quand ce que nous faisons
c'est live on peut parler du front du
sud maintenant le front du sud de l'inde
qui vient de la crimée
comment ça s'est passé à ces moments là
est ce que les forces russes ont
progressé facilement alors c'est le
feront clairement où l on avancer le
plus vite
avec enfin néanmoins il faut quand même
préciser quels alors là ils ont avancé
d'environ 100 kilomètres
au nord-ouest donc c'est énorme
pareil veut prudent les forces russes
ont pris une partie de personnes
visiblement pas toute la ville en tout
cas voilà il ya encore un doute
mais mais avant il l'est les forces ont
réussi ont énormément avancé vision il y
avait moins de défense ukrainienne la
défense ukrainienne visiblement se
focalise autour de kiev est par ailleurs
essaye de tenir le front de l'est près
de près de kharkiv alors juste pour un
petit rappel historique très rapide donc
la crimée au moment de la guerre fin de
la guerre de la révolution du maidan en
sébastopol en crimée c'est eux
le la base navale principal de la flotte
de la mer noire pour les russes c'est
l'accès aux berges chaude c'est
absolument stratégique
et donc par un mouvement séparatiste
kenney immédiatement en crimée qu'a
déclaré la crimée indépendante et
ensuite il me rattache un référendum de
rattachement à la réussir le mot
rattachement c'est le mot qu'utilisent
les rues
les ukrainiens pense que les ukrainiens
et
en occident on parle d'addiction parce
que juridiquement du point de vue du
droit international
c'est une annexion même si les russes ap
après diront que c'est le droit des
peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes comme au
kosovo comme etc enfin bref
on en occident on dit annexion
et donc du coup c'est là la crim elle
n'a pas d'accès thérèse direct avec la
russie sauf par le détroit de kertch
dont j'ai parlé enflammèrent d'alsace et
les allées la mer noire c'est là où je
passe la souris voilà et donc là les
russes ont construit très rapidement à
partir de 2014 un pont et des depuis des
semaines il y avait des enfants russes
qui arrivait en crimée et donc à une
énorme offensive qui par-delà et qui
part dans les deux directions
c'est à dire à l'ouest et à l'est alors
elle est on en a parlé déjà c'est pour
contrôler la mer d'azov
il a on le voit pas sur la carte mais on
sait les zones en fait voilà qui est qui
et qui est vrai que rentrer stratégique
on imagine alors qu'est stratégique mais
on va le voir qu'est moins stratégique
que l'autre au maire pour une raison
très simple c'est qu'en réalité les
russes contrôlent déjà la mer d'azov
puisque la mer d'azov elle est donc
fermée par le détroit de kertch et
franchement
aucun bateau qui n'a pas l'autorisation
de bahia les deux pays rentrent et voilà
et comme il n'y a pas vraiment de flotte
ukrainienne
non là
le bord le plus les rêves les plus
stratégiques c'est la mer noire on va
parler mais en tout cas les forces
russes avancent vers l'est là on le voit
pas sur la carte mais il ya une une
ville qui s'appelle
pas faire d'erreurs mais dit paul
visiblement qui est tombé
aux mains des russes est donc peut-être
que marie-paule du coût sera
la prochaine a en tout cas pris à la
fois entre le fond de l'ast et le front
alors donc du coup l'autre l'autre
partie du fond du sud c'est vers l'ouest
là encore on retrouve le marqueur
géographique du nieppe ce qui est très
important
hier assez rapidement dans la journée on
a compris que les russes avaient atteint
justement le nom est prêt en
l'occurrence l'embouchure du nieppe où
il ya donc cette ville de carson là
encore la situation est incertaine il
semblerait l'agente aux inconditionnels
déjà hier soir qu'il y a eu des troubles
russe qui est franchie la nièvre et
qu'il soit de l'autre côté alors
maintenant on sait pas ce qui va se
passer mais on peut imaginer aisément
qu'une certitude que les russes vont
chercher à pousser vers l'ouest et
notamment à pousser lauriane nikolaïev
qui est une grande ville d'ukraine yann
qui ne
historiquement c'était l'union
soviétique un chantier naval très
important mais surtout il ya la grande
ville d'odessa c'est la plus grande
ville
à l'ouest de l'ukraine est clairement si
les russes arrivés à odessa ça signifie
une chose très simple c'est que
l'ukraine n'a plus d'accès à la mer
voilà
et par ailleurs
ça veut dire aussi que la mer noire
devient entre guillemets un lac russe
s'annonce assez église toute la partie
en garde il en est là toute la partie
est et il aurait aussi toute la partie
nord de ce absolument donc ça on peut
imaginer que c'est stratégique mais
comme on connaît pas les objectifs
stratégiques de cette invasion russe
c'est bien compliqué de parler
précisément de sa mémé en tout cas au
dessin c'est sûr que c'est important et
puis par ailleurs symboliquement pour
les russes au dessin c'est une ville qui
a été fondée par catherine ii à la fin
du xviiie siècle donc il ya tout aussi
toute une mythologie
historique clairement servi par
vladimir poutine vladimir poutine il ya
il ya une
réécriture de l'histoire et au dessin
qui en ont une ville assez symbolique
pour les russes parce qu'elle était
construite par les russes au xviiie
siècle effectivement et on voit du coup
sûr cette sueur sur cette carte du coup
tous les to les différents accès et
l'ouest comme on le disait juste au
début a été bombardée aussi alors que
c'est trés finalement très loin de la
russie absolument mais là c'est ce que
je vous disais tout à l'heure celle
qu'ils ont c'est ce qu'on dit pas mal de
commentateurs mais
c'est une guerre un peu à l'américaine
c'est à dire on commence par frapper
massivement avant d'envoyer les troupes
au sol et alors quand je dis il ya eu
des frappes de haute précision c'est
bien mais avec cette idée d'une d'une
guerre chirurgicale avec énormément de
guillemets on sait en irak en libye est
ici que que c'est loin d'être le cas
mais en tout cas si vous voulez en
biélorussie il ya des batteries de
missiles iskander m conte tiré des
missiles
sa déportés de
500 et quelques kilomètres et puis aussi
des navires en mer noire qui visiblement
ont pu tirer des missiles de croisière
s'ils ont des frappes terrestres donc ça
c'est important il ya les frappes
de précision à très longue distance et
par ailleurs à côté de ça il ya quelque
chose qui va me notre tradition
soviétique qui demeure qui est une
tradition de d'artillerie un
déchaînement d'artillerie puis ensuite
on envoie les envoie les troupes
effectivement on peut être se pencher un
peu plus sur sur l'histoire en termes
pour le pour l'otan puisque c'est un peu
ça qui
joue énormément vous voulez en parler le
pendant cela il donc je vais essayer de
vous montrer cette autre carte que nous
avons fait par le service infographie du
figaro voilà c'est les pays de
l'otan et c'est la russie qui se
retrouvent est ce que tu peux nous
expliquer un peu ce qu'on voit sur cette
carte alexis alors en gros ce qu'on voit
donc vous voit l'ukraine qui est qui en
verre
ce qui est assez rigolo parce que quand
l'ukraine elle était indépendante en
1917 très brièvement de 17 à 22
justement c'était les verts qui étaient
face aux rouges effaçable enfin bref ça
c'est une anecdote mais quoi qu'il en
soit ce qu'on voit là sur cette carte
c'est l'avancé
progressive depuis 1991 de la frontière
de l'otan
vers l'est alors pour le dire très
brièvement
en 91
les russes nous disent et certains six
observateurs qui étaient présents dans
ce moment-là nous disent qu'il ya eu une
promesse
notamment des américains fait un grand
match of de ne pas avancer
les frontières de l'otan au delà de
l'allemagne de l'allemagne réunifiée
puisqu'on partir des 89 delà de la chute
du mur ça avait été un énorme enjeu et
gorbatchev avait reculé en acceptant que
l'allemagne dans son ensemble entre dans
le temps ce qui est ici du coup sûr sur
l'art alors il ya un conflit
historique les historiens ne sont pas
d'accord sur la question est ce qu'il ya
une promesse il est très clair qu'il n'y
a jamais vu de textes écrits qui disait
qu'il n'y aurait pas d' avancée de
l'otan vers l'est sur la question est ce
qu'il ya eu une promesse verbale très
franchement
on n'a pas assez de preuves pour le
savoir c'est parole contre parole il ya
des histoires extrêmement sérieux des
deux côtés qui disent qui lui promet ce
cap est une promesse dernièrement il ya
eu un
article non là dans la presse allemande
qui a révélé de nouveaux nouvelles
archives qui est inconnu jusque là qu'il
semble suggérer qui est bien une
promesse orale mais sur les skis le
cadre général à l'époque pouvant
rappeler le un peu d'histoire c'est
gorbatchev camp
quand ils voient que le mur c'est un peu
en train de de s'effondrer en tout cas
89 c'était c'était l'allemagne lui son
idée mais qui défendent est depuis
longtemps c'était l'idée de maison
commune européenne donc c'était l'idée
qui était soutenu par françois
mitterrand
de tourner la page de la guerre froide
et une grande architecture de sécurité
commune qui inclut la russie
mitterrand avait un projet de
confédération européenne caler dans ce
sens là on sait qu'entre par apprendre
la chronologie mais entre 89 et 91 ce
projet
a capoté littéralement ce qu est ce qui
est très clair c'est que les américains
eux
préféré de loin la solution de faire
avancer
les frontières de l'otan vers l'est mais
c'est pas seulement les mecs c'est aussi
principalement les pays les mieux même
concerner les pays d'europe de l'est ce
pour des raisons historiques on peut
tout à fait comprendre que les polonais
aient envie d'entrer
dans le temps enfin bref le résultat
c'est que le temps avançait vers l'est
et on sait très bien que sur ces
questions là parfois le réel compte
énormément mais la perception du réel
compte énormément et donc les russes là
dessus et il ya une sorte d'unité
nationale sur cette question là c'est
pas boutines c'est l'ensemble de la
classe politique russe depuis leur match
of en passant par helsinn considère que
les que les les occidentaux n'ont pas
respecté leur promesse de faire avancer
l'otan là on voit rapidement
donc les pays baltes et l'appareil pour
des raisons historiques on veut on peut
tout à fait comprendre qu'il ait balle
va y être dans le temps mais les pays
baltes sont dans l'otan déjà à la
frontière avec la russie estonie
lettonie lituanie si la pologne et dans
le temps il faut savoir que la pologne
est déjà la frontière russe puisqu'il ya
une petite enclave qui hongrie ce qui l
enclave de nos jeunes voilà l étoile à
kaliningrad donc en fait c'est déjà
hier déjà une frontière ruse avec le
temps voilà et
et bref toute l'europe centrale est
passé dans l'otan une grande partie de
l'ex yougoslavie on va pas rentrer dans
les détails
mais si vous voulez ben ça crée des
tensions et alors il ya les russes sont
obsédés mais pareil c'est pas poutine ce
bien avant ça fait des siècles obsédé
par l'idée d'être encerclés ils auraient
en territoire peut-être à cause de la
grand territoire et est donc pour eux
ils sont persuadés que l'avancé de
l'otan vers l'est ce n'est pas quelque
chose de défensif mais quelque chose de
sens si c'est ce qui c'est passé en
géorgie en 2008 aussi errigo et on
retrouve un peu ces mêmes ingrédients au
final alors en fait ce qu'il faut
comprendre et ça c'est très important
c'est que les russes dans les années 90
et 2000 et notamment poutine au moment
de son premier mandat
était relative relativement ouvert vers
la libye était assez pro américain enfin
premier cas il y avait un vrai dialogue
un vrai dialogue stratégique sur ces
questions là et il ya eu en 2007 grand
discours de 2 de poutine à munich où il
dit là c'est le retournement est il dit
aux américains aux européens là c'est
pas possible vous avez pas respecter vos
promesses et donc là je entre guillemets
je vous mets en garde
nous les russes on n'acceptera plus
et donc effectivement en 2007 discours
de munich 2008 la valeur des anguilles
et du coup là on voit sur ces sur ses
lauriers on connaît pas la jument
j'allais passer sans cela je crois alors
là il ya un tout petit bout de l'as que
tu montres leur l'occurrence c'est alors
voilà de l'aca voilà vous donc la
géorgie pareil directement à la
frontière
russe dans le caucase
2008 il ya un gouvernement il ya pro
occidentale qui est
qui arrivent au pouvoir c'était sa cage
billy est en fait au nord de la géorgie
il ya deux petits territoires qui
avaient déjà pris leur indépendance dès
1991 parce qu'ils étaient olsson et
russophile et saakachvili qui pensait
avant des garanties américaines et que
les russes n'avancerait pas
ba a décidé de reprendre ces deux
territoires grand mal lui en a pris
puisque les russes ont immédiatement
contre attaqué contre attaquer et se
sont pas arrêtés
astrid sud et l'abkhazie ils sont allés
au delà
haralambos bbc et là il ya une
négociation européenne
poutine s'est arrêtée l'armée russe est
revenue mais en abkhazie et ossétie du
sud ils ont déclaré l'indépendance de
ces deux républiques qui n'est reconnu
par quasiment qu'un état dans le monde
finalement le pays qui est un peu à part
dans ce dans cette carte c'est la
biélorussie très proche de la russie
fait
finalement et qui lui pour le coup ne se
rapproche plus du tout de ça c'est ça
c'est très important
en fait en 94 mais comme pour l'ukraine
il y avait eu un traité qui avait été
passé bref dans la constitution
biélorusse il était dit qu'il y avait
une dénucléarisation de la biélorussie
comme delà de l'ukraine est par ailleurs
il y avait une sorte de de nitro
neutralité diplomatique c'est à dire
qu'en fait la biélorussie n'était pas
aligné sur la russie eut n'était
évidemment pas non plus aligné sur sur
le temps
et ce qui s'est passé c'est que
loukachenko dont quel président
dictateur de de la galerie 6-2 pendant
très longtemps il a joué les américains
contre les russes donc à chaque fois que
les russes voulaient est un peu trop
gourmand il allait par les américains et
inversement et donc ils gardaient
pendant assez longtemps non pas une
indépendance il était calme dans le
giron de moscou mais ce n'était pas
complètement le pantin de poutine ce qui
s'est passé l'année dernière c'est qu'il
ya eu s'est fait réélire pour une énième
fois et sauf que cette élection était
complètement truquée
et que pour le coup il ya eu des
manifestations et en norme énorme en
biélorussie et qui clairement mis en
danger le régime de loukachenko
sauf qu'il a réussi à reprendre la main
mais enfin il a très bien compris que
son régime est extrêmement fragile qu'il
ne peut plus avoir le soutien de
l'occident est là du coup il est
vraiment depuis un an bien plus qu'avant
sous la coupe de la hausse y est
d'ailleurs il ya une modification cours
de lac de la constitution biélorusse ça
c'est un point important qui est passé
souligné mais qui pourrait supprimer
justement cette neutralité diplomatique
delà de la bière ici et y compris à la
fin du statut dénucléarisé de
l'halloween russie et lukashenko l'a dit
il pourrait à l'avenir accueillir des
armes nucléaires russes sur son sol
poutine en a pas parlé mais non cash and
co
on a parlé donc on a vraiment la russie
qu'à récupérer la russie les lois ici
qu'est vraiment la danse ont donc voilà
mais historiquement c'est très important
dans les courants pense la viste
de la russie sur ce qui est vraiment une
vision très slave delà de la russie anti
européenne et qui qui rêve d'une grande
aussi en fait les peuples de biélorussie
et d'ukraine sont des peuples russe et
donc qui naturellement vont revenir dans
le giron de la rue dans le giron de la
russie qui est un empire
voilà est clairement en juillet dernier
poutine a écrit un très très long
article sur l'histoire de larry craig de
l'ukraine oui dit précisément cela nous
d'une certaine manière il nous avait
prévenus s'étaient pas que des
considérations sécuritaires sur les
missiles sur l'autre sens mais que
c'était aussi quelque chose
d'identitaires du culturel et d'ailleurs
dans sa première interview il ya
quelques jours il avait mis en garde les
faits il avait reconnu les deux
républiques séparatistes du nom basse on
note qu'il a passé un tiers du temps à
parler de l'otan mais il a passé deux
tiers du temps avec la risée de
l'histoire de l'ukraine sur sur 1h10 de
discours effectivement c'est laisser
extrêmement sa feuille fait la boulie
vraiment mettre l'accent sur l'histoire
et sur le fait que l'ukraine finalement
pour lui devrait appartenir à la
réussite et sa wii alors là je pense
qu'il faut faire un tout petit point
historiquement a publié une
longue interview sur ce sujet là
l'ukraine
cesser le l'histoire d'un pays c'est une
race un drame c'est une tragédie parce
qu'il a toujours été pris entre des
zambiens c'est ça pour résumer une
graine
pendant très longtemps
il a été
il a fait partie de l'empiré russe sauf
et c'est un point de détail important
l'ouest de l'ukraine qui sont faits à
l'époque soviétique n'a jamais été dans
l'empiré russe
et pour reprendre l'histoire récente
c'était on va dire on va partir ça c'est
sur cette carte là pour voilà pour
l'ouest oui combien dans le vif c'est la
galicie la galicie il ya eu
une période liedson nous polonaise et
ensuite une période hausses seront
graves mais vif n'a jamais été russe
à part c'est paru c'était soviétique au
temps de la guerre froide mais en
revanche tout laisse de de l'ukraine
c'est ce qu'on appelait la petite russie
et au sud d'un nouveau russie la
nouvelle russie qui avaient été pris sur
les terres de l'empiré ottoman
ces terres là on fait partie de l'empiré
russe on va dire à partir de
l'effondrement de ce qu'on appelait
l'union delà de la lituanie la pologne
à la fin du xviie siècle est une grande
avancée russe ella ont souhaité lui un
partage entre le l'empiré
austro-hongrois l'empiré russe et l'
empire ottoman qui était au sud est car
fumer donc c'est vraiment une histoire
d'un pays qui étaient pris entre des
empires ça n'a jamais été véritablement
pays il y avait eu un moment 1 et
manassé les cosaques mais ce n'était pas
vraiment un pays en fait très rapidement
comme il n'arrivait pas à contrôler le
pays tout seul face à la pologne ils ont
passé serment avec l'aris idée le xviie
pour dire au roi voilà on se met sous
votre sous votre groupe
très bien mais c'est vraiment très
intéressant cette partie historique
forcément pour comprendre ce qui se
passe sur l'otan on en parle est aussi
tout à l'heure sur les sur les sur les
sur les forces en présence de l'otan
alors c'est pas cette carte là c'est
celle qui en dessous de l'article
d'ailleurs c'est son article vous pouvez
retrouver sur le figaro que je vous ai
bien sûr je conseille d'aller voir
vraiment très intéressant c'est
alors je crois que ça s'est elle a même
eu oui celle-là c'était la même
voie c'est là c'est le système de
défense finalement de l'otan
qui est qui qui qui est en place
alors
voilà qu'on veut qu'on voit ici
avec donc les différences les
différentes forces en présence parce
qu'il ya ça aussi qui est très important
pour la numéro 8 est absolument pas ce
qu'il faut savoir
c'est que il ya le fait d'appartenir à
l'otan
il ya l'article 5 de défense collective
qui lie tous les membres en cas d'
attaque mais il ya aussi des dispositifs
militaires et de ce point de vue là il
ya certains dispositifs militaires qui
de très longue date
énerve c'est les rhumes c'est un petit
mot notamment le déploiement progressif
en pologne en roumanie
d'un bouclier antimissile dans les
années 90 quand clinton
avait lancé ce projet il disait aux
russes mais n'ayez pas peur c'est pas du
tout contre vous c'est contre les états
voyous et notamment contre l'iran les
russes n'ont jamais cru cela et et
craignent que ce bouclier antimissile
affaiblissent la capacité de dissuasion
nucléaire
de la russie
et ça c'est un point très important
de savoir qu'en 2003 les américains se
sont retirés d'un traité qui se paie du
traité abm antibalistiques me sall qui
datait la guerre froide et qui encadre
et tressé être très sévèrement la
défense antimissile et nous claironner
sur sony mais ça y est vous vous
attaquez n'ont pas n'ont pas ben ali
vont nous attaquer mais en tout cas ils
veulent créer un bouclier antimissile à
la frontière s de l'europe pour vaincre
notre capacité de dissuasion nucléaire
et ça c'est un point extrêmement
important depuis très longtemps et il ya
eu un deuxième point en 2018 il ya
donald trump qui est sorti
unilatéralement d'un grand traité la
guerre froide qui s'appelait le traité
inf pour la faire bref c'est un traité
qui interdit tous les missiles
terrestres offensif d'une portée de 500
à 5500 km ce qu'on appelle des missiles
de portée intermédiaire et c'était la
crise des euromissiles dans un 80 cédait
1,88 qu'ils avaient signé ce traité pour
éviter que le lord devient devienne un
champ de bataille est donc donald trump
on est sortis en 2018 alors il disait
que les russes tricher sur le système
iskander m dont ai parlé tout à l'heure
ce qui est très probable est-ce qui est
même quasiment sûr
mais du coup ça a complètement mis à
plat le tout le système juridique de
contrôle des armements qui a été hérité
de la guerre froide et ça c'est
extrêmement dangereux et tant qu'on
pensait que la crise en ukraine était
question négociations etc c'était un
point important des négociations c'était
comment reconstruire une architecture de
défense en europe avec des acteurs
européens et surtout le duo paul
états-unis russie wii qui revient
finalement à l'ordre du jour aujourd'hui
complètement complètement ce conte ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui se recréer c'est
le sait le bloc occidental au otanien
contre le bloc de l'urss fin l'ancien
blog c'est un bloc de l'urss sauf
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas le bloc de lurs
et césar est ici plus peut-être la chine
c'est ce qui est aussi le grand enjeu
stratégique notamment pour pour les
états unis mais en tout cas c ales
hemsky a parlé hier d'un rideau de fer
qui s'abattaient
en europe entre le monde libre et la
russie c'est très clair que vu nova ions
russe
total de l'ukraine
bah c'est sûr que un rideau de fer en
train de tomber sur sur l'europe il n'y
a pas de doute sur sa même si on connaît
pas la suite cela va très bien merci
beaucoup alexis d'avoir été avec nous
pour mes relais de toutes ses cartes je
vous rappelle qu'elle soit retrouvée sur
le site du figaro vous pouvez tout les
retrouver bien évidemment surtout celles
qu'on met à jour plusieurs fois dans la
journée évidemment c'est celle que je
vous ai montré en début de live attendez
je vais essayer de la retrouver elle est
ici voilà c'est décidé c'est les
différentes
sélections aux attaques et les mises à
jour plusieurs fois par jour et je vais
de ce pas d'ailleurs merci alex idée
d'avoir pris un peu de temps parce que
ton nul et que je veux tu as beaucoup de
deux travaillent effectivement continuer
de suivre nos lives et nos articles sur
le site du figaro on a ouvert un direct
pour tout suivre en temps réel je vous
remercie en tout cas d'abord été très
nombreux à nous suivre aujourd'hui et je
vous dis à bientôt sur figaro live